Once again, I have some crazy
relationship between x and y.
And just to get a sense of
what this might look like,
if you plot all the x's and y's
that satisfy this relationship,
you get this nice
little clover pattern.
And I plotted this
off of Wolfram Alpha.
But what I'm curious
about in this video,
as you might imagine
from the title,
is to figure out
the rate at which y
is changing with respect to x.
And we're going to have
to do it implicitly.
We're going to have to find the
implicit derivative of this.
We're going to have to derive
this implicitly or take
the derivative of it implicitly.
So let's apply our
derivative operator
to both sides of the derivative
with respect to x on the left
and the derivative with
respect to x on the right.
So once again, we
apply our chain rule.
The derivative of something to
the third power with respect
to that something is
going to be three times
that something squared.
And then we have
to multiply that
times the derivative of the
something with respect to x.
So the derivative of this
thing with respect to x
is going to be 2x,
that's the derivative
of x squared with respect to
x, plus the derivative of y
squared with respect
to y is going
to be 2y times the derivative
of y with respect to x.
Once again, we're applying the
chain rule right over here.
The derivative of something
squared with respect
to the something, which is
2y, times the derivative
of the something with
respect to x, which is dy dx.
Now, that is going
to be equal to what
we have on the right hand side.
So we have a 5 times x
squared times y squared.
We can take the 5 out
of the picture for now.
Take the 5 onto the-- take
it out of the derivative.
The derivative of
5 times something
is the same thing as 5
times the derivative.
And now we can apply
the product rule.
So it's going to be 5 times
the derivative of x squared
is just going to be
2x times y squared.
So that's just the derivative
of the first function
times the second function.
Plus the first function,
not taking its derivative,
x squared times the derivative
of the second function.
Well, what's the derivative of
y squared with respect to x?
Well, we already figured it out.
It's the derivative of
y squared with respect
to y, which is 2y times the
derivative of y with respect
to x.
Let me make it clear
what I just did.
This is this, and then this
is when I took its derivative.
So that is when I applied
the derivative operator.
Similarly, that is that.
And when I applied the
derivative operator,
I got that.
The derivative with respect
to x right over there.
So let's see if we can
somehow solve for dy dx.
So what I'm going to do
on the left hand side
is I'm just going to distribute
this purple thing onto both
of these terms.
So if you distribute
this purple thing
onto this term
right over here, you
get 3 times 2x, which is 6x,
times x squared plus y squared,
squared.
And then if you distribute
this purple stuff
on to this one right over
here you get plus, let's see,
2y times 3 is 6y times x
squared plus y squared.
Let me make sure.
2y times 3 is 6y times x
squared plus y squared,
squared, and then I'll keep
the dy dx in that green color.
dy dx is equal to, well,
we can multiply the 5 times
this business right over here.
And so everything
that's not a dy
dx term maybe I will
do in purple now.
So you do 5 times
this stuff right
over here, which gives
you 10xy squared.
And then 5 times all
of this right over here
is going to be plus
10x squared y dy dx.
Did I do that right?
Yep, that looks
just about right.
And now we have to
solve for dy dx.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to subtract this 10x squared.
I'm going to subtract
the 10x squared y dy
dx from both sides.
10x squared y dy dx.
Derivative.
That's not green.
Derivative of y
with respect to x.
Going to subtract
that from both sides
so that I can get it
on the left hand side.
dy dx.
And I'm going to subtract
this business, this 6x times
all this craziness
from both sides.
So minus 6x times x squared
plus y squared, squared.
Let me subtract it
from here as well.
Minus 6x x squared
plus y squared squared.
And what are we left with?
Well, these guys cancel out.
On the left hand
side right over here,
we are left with 6y times
x squared plus y squared,
squared minus 10x
squared y times
dy dx, the derivative
of y with respect to x.
The derivative of
y with respect to x
is equal to-- these
characters cancel out--
and we are left with 10xy
squared minus 6x times
x squared plus y
squared, squared.
And now if we want
to solve for dy dx,
we just divide both
sides of this equation
by this business
right over here.
And you get the derivative
of y with respect to x.
And we deserve a drum roll now.
The derivative of
y with respect to x
is equal to all of this stuff.
And I'm just going
to copy and paste it.
So let me copy and paste it.
All of that stuff
over all of this stuff
over all of that stuff.
Once again, just going
to copy and paste it.
And I just have to draw
the little fraction symbol.
So we are done.
We have figured out-- and it
was kind of a hairy expression,
but it didn't take
us too long-- what
the derivative of y with
respect to x at any point is.
So what you'd want to do
is if you want to say,
hey, what is the slope of
the tangent line right at--
let me do this in a color
that you can actually see.
What is the slope of the tangent
line right at that point?
Well, you'd want to figure out
what the x-coordinate of that
point it so you
could say maybe x
is this value right over here.
And then you can solve
for y to figure out
what the y value would be.
And then you would
chunk that x and
y into this hairy
expression right over here
to figure out the slope
of the tangent line.